[Music]
in a tough year for everyone marvel's
managed to give us something to look
forward to we've had a string of
adventures with characters we know and
love across five tv shows and 36
episodes of content thanks marvel of
course it also came with what feels like
seven years of previously ons and
opening credits so here's a sin instead
this bishop okay one immediate sin
removal for the masterful vincent
d'onofrio his kingpin [ __ ] rules that
said the show waited far too long to
introduce him as a villain which
undermined the respect his terror
deserves there are no lines in this
business but there should be because
without such lines lies a world where
meat grinders are attached to the edge
of desks and here's a random jug filled
with miniatures you know just in case
you forgot we were in a larper's house
and needed a reminder you
should go home you should be with your
family you can still make it in time for
christmas kate you're my partner nice
cinnamon and all but i feel like there's
not a widow's chance in end game that he
was leaving rather marvel just enjoys
toying with our emotions with this will
they won't they partner bullsh beat it
curtains
she's turned on us okay let's have a
look at kingpin's abilities criminal
mastermind highly intelligent above
average strength and durability nope not
seeing telepathy anywhere so how the
hell did he see through maya's expert
level poker face and figure out she was
ready to betray him fletching soldering
danger spike poof powder clippers
callbacks label making excitement most
of these labels make sense but
icebreaker raises some questions how
often does hawkeye come up against ice
in such quantities as to require a
specific arrow either that or perhaps it
just provides interesting conversation
starters so if you're gonna do this i
just wanna know you're ready and
short-term memory be damned as clint
appears to have forgotten that kate has
already been doing this in stating she
is well aware of the risk for all of the
some episodes fighting aliens with a
stick and a string okay kate we get it
he's willfully unequipped to be an
avenger lay off the guy already sheesh
even disney can't escape a comcast sin
what are assets what are threats dude
what about your assets okay there's no
sheld no stark no cap but what about
sward spider-man or even ant-man or does
he only get to swap phone numbers when
he becomes an avenger himself it's a
weird flag spin before title of my sex
tape mom said i was going to get your
wine collection kids a founder touching
your covert in your comms when you speak
what's the point of it being discreet if
you bring attention to the damn thing
every time you use it
i've never dodged a sniper's bullet
before so i don't mean to judge too
harshly here but would mr sniper have a
much harder time hitting you if you
crawled below the window as opposed to
above it just a thought what kind of
company decorates their prep area with
christmas decor like this do you think
the employees give a holly jolly [ __ ]
about lights draped across the room well
they do but only because the lights are
in the way of their serving dishes it's
your time bringing a sword to a sniper
fight i distinctly remember elena
telling kate to stay out of her way and
i can't understand why she avoids
incapacitating her immediately sure was
thoughtful of whoever opened all the
doors in this series of adjacent rooms
so that we could watch the room to room
battle sequence sure the director of
photography thanks them for their
service
how did elena know that clint was going
to be at this window she knew he's on
the 12th floor but that still covers a
lot of windows if she didn't know and
still got it right then wow is this a
stroke of good luck only to be matched
by this shot missing clint
yes but she should be a flattened and
super dead cape pancake a pancake
does this really need an audible beep
wouldn't a silent beep always be
preferable no matter the mission i think
even penn and teller would struggle to
work out what kind of dark magic qazi
used to surprise hawkeye from out of
[ __ ] nowhere here dear hinchman
thanks for not shooting clint
immediately love your friend the plot
this episode has been a hoot but i'll be
damned if show has time for this we're
trained professionals but that's not
enough right now are you [ __ ] kidding
me with this of course that's enough
what's the message here are you telling
the world to be a police officer or a
firefighter isn't enough in order to
help you have to be dressed up in a
costume and play hero isn't that exactly
the opposite of what hawkeye has been
saying this entire show hey bros kate
fires three arrows here but there are
five gun-toting tracksuit guys in total
were the other two seriously scared off
by a bow and arrow and a bit of high
ground kate
where's our backup the non-vengers here
managed to time this entrance so that it
immediately answered father clint
mystery's question also what about the
actual backup where the police are
multiple gunshots in a [ __ ] sniper at
rockefeller center not enough to draw in
new york's finest also also how many
people have been hurt or trampled in the
time it took these guys to suit up and
why do they think this will make the
public any more likely to take them
seriously than if they were dressed as
oh i don't know actual emergency service
people this acid arrow is all kinds of
the [ __ ] if it impacted the tree
here how did it manage to dissolve this
perfect wedge that would somehow require
the acid to know that it needs to
dissolve more of the outside of the tree
than the initial point of impact i'm
willing to believe that through
channeling his inner macgyver clint
managed to create an arrowhead absurdly
powerful enough to turn all of these
lampposts into electromagnets but an
electromagnet powerful enough to pull
guns from meters away would also likely
end up telling us far too much about who
has what pierced and where oh my god you
wore it you are surrounded why is this
costuming a thing right now this is not
humorous this is ridiculous you need to
get off this ice okay only way off this
ice
is up those stairs well yeah if you're
insisting on walking out of there i mean
hawkeye managed to pack an arrow more
powerful than 20 mri machines but
somehow doesn't have one with a
grappling hook and rope to get them out
of this ice rink here
take these i have no idea which arrows
i'm giving you because i won't look at
the labels we made earlier but
regardless i have a feeling they will be
situationally specific to your exact
needs there's no denying that the acme
arrows are entertaining but are they
really worth the effort of all that home
brewing how are either of these arrows
any better than shooting the bad guys in
the legs with a regular arrow i mean
this guy's definitely looking at an
amputation and who knows what happened
to this poor bastard does that arrow
come with a parachute the biggest
problem with this fight is that it's
over if even two or three of these thugs
have a gun instead they just keep
running in a few at a time with a
variety of pipes and baseball bats so
that we can see our heroes make use of
the quiver of many things
what exactly was marvin harry's plan
here drive the van as fast as they can
hope they get enough air to fly into the
ice rink at best straight up killing
hawkeye and kate who they couldn't have
possibly been able to see or at worst
just killing themselves in a hideous
automotive mashup
kate actually did them a solid here
owl my god kate your mom just came out
the side door thank you for that
entirely unhelpful description of which
slide door she could exit from on a
massive building with multiple points of
departure
[Music]
shot okay awesome call back and i
suppose none of this is particularly
impossible but you always have to ask
yourself wouldn't it be easier if like
wouldn't it be easier if hawkeye pulled
out another explodey arrow instead of
this trick shot that he himself admitted
to only having pulled off a few times or
wouldn't it be easier for qazi to step
to one side instead of relying on the
force or some to catch this arrow or
wouldn't it be easier to base your
superhero show around an actual
superhero prepare yourself for the
whiplash of several boss battles all
climaxing at the same time if you
thought the they survived this a-thon
was over you were wrong i need to know
what happened my goodness marvel loves
previously on segments so much it's
working one right into the middle of its
damn finale strike
yeah keep the massive super strength
deadly boss in the room with you when
you should have and myself and thanos
mean this respectfully gone for the head
kate all of the survives all of this
this
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
works police arrive just in time to be
of no [ __ ] use to anybody in a finale
cliche
oh
now you whistle to save your ass not
before when elena was whipping your face
with her thwacky beat stick she talked
about you all the time elena
we are with hawkeye we're essentially
avengers well i suppose if they let
hawkeye in you took on kingpin all by
yourself not many people walk away from
something like that yeah you're telling
us we're the confused people who watch
kate get pummeled by kingpin and then
walk away like she just had an oopsie
fall down a teensy flight of cotton
stairs
[Applause]
uh
my goodness i wish clint would make up
his damn mind about whether or not he
wants the ronin suit he gets rid of it
kate finds it he takes it from kate he
then leaves it in kate's burning
apartment then goes back to rescue it
and now he's burning it again honestly
this relationship is almost as
frustrating as steven bucky
i said almost can i ask you something if
the question is anything other than are
we breathing toxic fumes emitted from a
flaming suit that has been soaked in
your sweat and the blood of your enemies
should we be concerned then i'm adding
all the sins what do you think of lady
hawk oh oh no i think maybe i made this
full song extra credit scene exists
because of the sin from episode 1 and
i'm not sorry regardless i can sin this
all day
you should be dead you got hit by a car
i mean are you even human
[Music]
a man came in here earlier
a dead man and that means what to me
i believe he had an animal with him it
was a gift i gave him a pet cat
tony stark was able to build this in a
cave
with a box of scraps before we get
started
does anyone want to get out
michael
[Music]
either one of you know where the
smithsonian is i'm here to pick up a
fossil
she sacrificed yourself
understand
you sacrifice yourself for me not even
know her name sometimes family doesn't
see
eye to
i'm still alive but i'm very badly
injured it doesn't happen
too often but it's not that common it
doesn't happen to every guy and it is a
big deal